la séance est ouverte
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
le compte-rendu analytique de la
présidence séance a été distribuée
j'imagine qu'il n'y a pas d'observation
le procès-verbal est adopté sous le
réserves d'usage
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent Burgaud
a pour une mise au point au sujet d'un
vote monsieur Burgaud merci monsieur le
Président je souhaite faire la mise au
point suivante sur le scrutin public
numéro 8 Mac OL ma collègue jouait le
garage souhaite ne pas prendre par au
vote
de votre mise au point elle sera publiée
au Journal officiel et figurant dans
l'analyse politique du scrutin concerné
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi créant une aide
universelle d'urgence pour les victimes
de violences conjugales présentées par
Madame Valérie léthard et plusieurs de
ses collègues à la demande du groupe
Union centriste dans la discussion
générale la parole est d'abord à madame
la Présidente Valérie l'état auteur de
la proposition de loi pour 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
tout d'abord je tiens à vous faire part
du plaisir et de la satisfaction que
j'ai devoir aujourd'hui cette
proposition de loi examinée par notre
assemblée
c'était d'universel d'urgence
qui vise à combler un réellement lorsque
les victimes subissant des violences
conjugales rencontre des difficultés à
s'extraire de l'emprise de leur conjoint
violent en raison de la dépendance
financière
cette dépendance financière peut faire
renoncer au départ ou forcer les
victimes de violences conjugales qui ont
franchi le pas à renoncer à revenir en
arrière
je dis notre proposition car je tiens à
associer les équipes du conseil
départemental du Nord qui sont ici
présentes avec qui je travaille depuis
plusieurs mois sur ce dispositif qui est
au final le résultat de nos nombreux
échanges avec les associations
compétentes les travailleurs sociaux les
services de gendarmerie et de police le
procureur la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales c'est ce travail de terrain
qui nous a fait imaginer le dispositif
proposé aujourd'hui et que nous avons
d'ores et déjà décidé d'expérimenter
dans le Valenciennois
je tiens bien sûr particulièrement et
également à remercier notre rapporteur
Jocelyne guidez qui a su s'emparer de ce
texte on comprendrent les enjeux et
l'enrichir utilement lors de son passage
en commission
le président de la République a fait des
droits des femmes et de la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes une des
grandes causes du quinquennat à ce titre
le 3 septembre 2019 le gouvernement
lançait le Grenelle des violences
conjugales lequel a débouché sur un plan
d'action global est inédit Madame
Elisabeth borne première ministre a
renouvelé l'engagement du gouvernement
en faveur de cette cause et il le faut
car les chiffres sont là et ils sont
glaçants en 2020 en France hors homicide
les forces de sécurité ont enregistré
159400 victimes de violences conjugales
commises par leur partenaire soit une
hausse de 10% sur un an
en 2021 143 morts violentes au sein du
couple ont été recensés contre 125
l'année précédente cela signifie 18
victimes en plus dans l'arrondissement
de Valenciennes territoires dans lequel
nous avons imaginé cette aide les
statistiques du parquet sont
particulièrement inquiétantes chaque
année le service d'aide aux victimes
accompagne 1000 victimes de violences
conjugales
en 2021 les services de police et de
gendarmerie ont eu à traiter en moyenne
8 cas de violences familiales chaque
jour face à ce constat alarmant il est
bien sûr plus que nécessaire de
s'interroger sur la façon de prévenir
ces violences d'anticiper de protéger
d'agir en amont sur ce sujet je ne peux
que soutenir sinon inciter le
gouvernement à faire davantage pour la
prévention en lien avec les
professionnels de terrain pour pour leur
donner les moyens d'agir un vrai travail
doit être fait en amont et à ce titre je
remercie félicite mes collègues Laurence
Rossignol Laurence Cohen Nicole durant
ton Loïck Hervé Françoise Laborde Noël
Rossin au nom de la délégation du droit
des femmes dont le rapport d'information
présenté en juin 2018 sur prévenir et
combattre les violences faites aux
femmes un enjeu de société apporté
énormément de propositions riche de leur
constats points de vigilance c'est 36
recommandations effectuées feraient une
excellente feuille de route madame la
ministre pour ces mesures de prévention
mais il est également urgent d'apporter
une réponse adaptée rapide assez victime
une fois l'emprise du conjoint violent
malheureusement établie aider une
victime qui trouve la force d'aller
porter plainte de demander une
ordonnance de protection qui trouve la
force de quitter le foyer conjugal alors
même que cela représente un choix
parfois tout aussi effrayant que de
rester subir les violences de son
conjoint là et le cœur de la présente
proposition de loi ainsi en créant une
aide universelle d'urgence pour les
victimes de violences conjugales on
accorde un droit à s'émanciper à
s'échapper de cette emprise générée par
une dépendance financière que le
conjoint violent assure elle car trop
souvent les victimes de violences sont
contraintes de retrouver le foyer
conjugal très peu de temps après l'avoir
quitté faute d'autonomie financière
immédiate ce constat mes chers collègues
ce sont les professionnels de terrain
qui me l'ont dressé j'ai souhaité faire
de ce dispositif une aide universelle le
pré octroyé n'étant pas la condition de
ressources ni de statut pourquoi parce
que tant la victime est vigible au RSA
ou que celle ou celui qui a des revenus
ou un patrimoine les moins de 25 les
plus de 25 les retraités hommes ou
femmes les violences l'emprise n'épargne
personne n'oublions pas que la rétention
de moyens de paiement ou de titres par
le conjoint violent et fréquent
l'objectif est donc de garantir aux
victimes les conditions financières
nécessaires pour leur permettre de se
libérer de celle-ci et ce le plus vite
possible c'est pourquoi le dispositif
répond également au caractère de
l'urgence qu'impose ces situations des
conditions de survie des victimes leurs
capacité à se mettre à l'abri le plus
rapidement possible et déterminant pour
elle-même et quelquefois leurs enfants
dans ces situations plus que dans tout
autre le temps est compté le présent
texte invendait avec efficacité par
notre rapporteur Jocelyne guidez en
commission ainsi que certains collègues
qui
ou qui ont proposé ou qui proposent des
amendements et bien prévoit ainsi tout
d'abord un délai de déblocage du prêt
alloué par la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales de 72 heures soit trois jours
ouvrés madame la rapporteur cette durée
n'est pas un choix arbitraire mais juste
un équilibre entre le besoin d'une
solution à court terme pour les victimes
et la capacité des services compétents
de la CAF à instruire la demande le plus
rapidement possible
s'inspirant des mécanismes extra légaux
d'action sociale de la branche famille
le montant retenu par cette annonce
d'urgence versée en trois manxualités au
maximum et l'équivalent du Revenu de
Solidarité Active je souhaite que nos
débats n'exclut pas celui de l'impact
budgétaire de la mesure proposée puisque
des critiques ont pu être émises et nous
nous serons faites au-delà du drame
humain et familial que constitue les
violences au sein du couple avec les
conséquences dramatiques humaines que
cela peut entraîner pour la victime
comme pour les enfants nous avons monté
un dispositif utile et financièrement
maîtrisé si besoin en été de le
justifier l'impact budgétaire sur les
finances publiques n'a aucune commune
mesure avec les conséquences financières
d'une mise à l'abri de la victime et de
ses enfants quand cela est le cas quand
vous savez que un placement une journée
en maison de l'enfance c'est 200 euros
c'est à dire 6000 euros par mois 6000
euros par mois pour réparer et de façon
absolument pas satisfaisante une maman
et ses enfants on voit bien l'intérêt de
cette mesure de bon sens en outre un
mécanisme de remboursement mettant à
contribution l'auteur de violence est
prévue une subrogation serait ainsi
possible de la casse dans des droits des
victimes pour se constituer partie civil
et demander en leur nom la réparation du
préjudice subi l'idée simple faire payer
l'auteur des violences pour une
situation dont il est responsable enfin
il s'agit là d'une disposition vitale à
l'efficacité du dispositif proposé le
président du conseil départemental sera
informée dès la transmission de la
demande à la CAF afin d'engager
immédiatement la compagnement social de
la victime aux côtés effectivement de
cette aide concrètement ça signifie un
accompagnement global de la victime dès
le dépôt de plainte l'ordonnance de
protection ou le signalement par un
travailleur social
celui-ci sera la personne ressource tout
au long du parcours de rebond de la
victime car rappelons-le l'objectif
recherché non seulement de sécuriser les
situations fragiles mais aussi et
surtout d'amener une indépendance
pérenne cela passe forcément par un
accompagnement multidimensionnel
logement des marchés administratives
accompagnement juridiques accompagnement
santé psychologique insertion
professionnelle pour lesquelles les
travailleurs sociaux des départements
des CCAS sont tous désignés ils agiront
comme facilitateur tout en étant les
garants des étapes de parcours en
coordonnant les partenaires
c'était d'universel travaillée en bonne
intelligence avec les acteurs de terrain
permet d'offrir un résultat non
seulement opérationnel mais demandez et
fortement attendu par les victimes de
violence qui cherchent une mise à l'abri
mais aussi à retrouver cette
indépendance économique administrative
et par tout le maillage des travailleurs
sociaux associations structure d'aide
acteurs judiciaires qui se battent
chaque jour pour tenter et bien de
changer la vie de leur victime voire de
sauver des vies monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre mes chers collègues
quel que soit notre place dans
l'hémicycle quel que soit et qu'elle
soit nos convictions politiques nous
rejetons toutes et tous la violence
c'est violentes conjugales détruisent la
vie de trop nombreuses victimes de trop
nombreuses familles elles touchent
toutes les catégories de notre société
notre pays c'est toujours grandi à
protéger les plus fragiles les victimes
d'actes de violence c'était d'universel
s'adresse à l'ensemble des victimes de
violences conjugales quelle que soit
leur sexe leur origine leur statut ou
leur âge elle se veut un moyen de rendre
la dignité de personnes victimes et aux
personnes victimes de relever la tête de
s'extraire d'une situation personnelle
qui n'apporte que souffrance et douleurs
elle sera je l'espère si vous l'adoptez
tout simplement un moyen supplémentaire
et essentiel manquant à notre dispositif
d'accompagnement de mettre à mettre à
disposition de notre République pour
endiguer ce fléau et enfin et bien avoir
l'ensemble de conditions réunies pour
réussir cet objectif que nous appelons
tous et toutes de nos vœux
la parole est maintenant madame Jocelyne
guidez rapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales pour 10 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales mes chers
collègues
la présidente Valérie Létard chère
Valérie a rappelé le contexte douloureux
dans lequel s'inscrit cette proposition
de loi en dépit de la mobilisation des
pouvoirs publics les violences commises
au sein du couple perdurent à un niveau
élevé dans l'Hexagone une enquête
statistique estime à 295000 le nombre
annuel de victimes de violences
conjugales entre 2011 et 2018 dont 72%
de femmes la violence au sein du couple
est aussi prégnante en outre-mer une
étude de l'Inde de 2018 révèle que près
d'une femme interrogée sur cinq se
déclare en situation de violence
conjugales en Martinique et Guadeloupe
la profession de loi en temps répond à
cet enjeu et plus de sa force dans les
retours concrets d'expérience Valérie
Létard en effet présenté le travail
qu'elle mène avec le département et la
caisse d'allocations familiales du Nord
pour mettre en place un prix d'urgence
et un accompagnement global pour les
victimes de violences conjugales
identifiées par les services sociaux
le texte est issu du constat empirique
d'un déficit à combler dans les
politiques publiques que nous déployons
en faveur des victimes de violences
conjugales il convient de les aider à
quitter définitivement leur partenaire
violent en leur apportant une aide
cruciale dans des délais très réduits
les données issues des appels au numéro
39-19 violence femme info montrent que
59% des victimes souhaitent quitter le
domicile conjugal tandis que 18% de
victimes indiquent avoir effectué
plusieurs départs du domicile il est
donc très difficile à la femme de
réussir à couper définitivement les
ponts avec son tortionnaire or la
précarité économique ou les incertitudes
financières figurent souvent parmi les
freins du départ des victimes ces
dernières peuvent être sans emploi sans
prestation sociale ou bien disposer de
ressources propres mais en être privé
par la violence ou l'emprise économique
dont le conjoint violent fait preuve
les moyens employés par les auteurs de
violence pour placer leurs victimes dans
une dépendance économique sont nombreux
chantage financier confiscation des
ressources des moyens de paiement
comportement visant à placer la victime
dans des surendettements personnels dès
lors comment donner les moyens
financiers aux victimes de s'extirper de
leur environnement violent la propulsion
de loi choisit d'accorder une aide
d'urgence débloquée en trois jours
versées par la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales pendant trois mois ce besoin
de créer une aide d'urgence et
d'ailleurs un constat partagé sur nos
bancs une propulsion de loi à l'objectif
similaire déposé par notre collègue
Michel Gréau adapté le régime existant
du revenu de solidarité active pour
permettre aux caves de verser des
avances sur droit supposées au RSA
financés par le Département la provision
de loi que nous examinons prévoit un
dispositif suis génériste sous la forme
d'un prêt de rap qui se rapprocherait de
près d'honneur que les conseils
d'administration des CAF peuvent
librement consentir au type de leur
politique d'action sociale
risquerait de gêner la mise en oeuvre de
la loi elle a donc retenue des
conditions d'octroi précises elle a
ainsi conditionné la délivrance de
l'avance un ordonnance de protection ou
un dépôt de plainte attestant de
violences conjugales ces deux critères
étaient déjà prévus à titre illustratif
par le texte initial cependant nous
savons bien que beaucoup de femmes
n'osent pas pousser la porte de la
gendarmerie ou de la police et dénoncer
l'effet qu'à subissent de même
5800 ordonnances de protection ont été
délivrés en 2021 par les justes aux
affaires familiales c'est pourquoi afin
de ne pas trop restreindre l'accès à ce
prix d'urgence la Commission a ouvert la
prestation aux victimes de violence
attestée par un signalement adressé au
procureur de la République s'appuyant
sur une nouvelle disposition prévue par
la loi du 30 juillet 2020 visant à
protéger les victimes de violences
conjugales certains centres hospitaliers
ont contractualisé avec le parquet afin
de faciliter avec l'accord de la
personne les signalements des victimes
prises en charge médicalement l'avance
d'urgence pour ainsi s'appliquer à cette
situation
l'article premier prévoit également que
des allocataires de l'avance bénéficient
des droits accessoires et prestations du
RSA à côté du dispositif financier la
victime doit pouvoir être aidé comme
c'est déjà souvent le cas par les
associations ou les travailleurs sociaux
des collectivités locales la Commission
a précisé que ces droits accessoires
comprennent également un accompagnement
social et professionnel adapté à leur
situation à leur situation à l'instar de
celui délivré au bénéficiaire du RSA la
Commission a également adoptée un
amendement déposé par notre collègue
notre collègue victoire jaxmin ici
présente permettant aux bénéficiaires de
l'avance d'urgence d'être domicilié des
droits auprès d'un sang communal ou
intercommunal d'action sociale ou d'un
autre organisme agréé
enfin la Commission a précisé les règles
de récupération des avances lesquelles
seraient très proche des modalités déjà
existantes pour les prix consentis par
les cafs la dette pourra ainsi être
remboursée en une ou plusieurs échéances
si le bénéficiaire le souhaite sinon
elle sera récupérée par retenue sur les
prestations sociales par ailleurs
versées par les caisses ces dernières
pourront décider de remise ou de
réduction de créances cette possibilité
n'est pas hypothétique les conseils
d'administration de caisse devront faire
preuve de discernement pour ne pas
ajouter une dette à des situations de
précarité ou de surendettement la
propulsion de loi prévoit également un
mécanisme inédit de subrogation des
caves dans les droits des victimes de se
constituer partie civils pour demander
en leur nom la récupération du préjudice
supplie ce mécanisme serait applicable
que lorsque les victimes renoncent à
leurs droits ce qui n'est pas une
situation rare la récupération de la
créance de la CAF pour alors se faire
sur les dommages et intérêts prononcés
aux bénéfices de la victime ce qui
permettra de faire l'auteur des
violences en lui et place de la victime
l'article 2 de la propulsion de loi
prévoit des mesures ambitieuses en
disposant que la victime déposant
plainte pour l'effet de violence
conjugales devra informer par l'officier
ou l'agent de police judiciaire de la
possibilité de demander l'avance
d'urgence plus encore le gendarme aux
policier plaintient devra enregistrer la
demande de la victime et la transmettre
à la CAF compétente ainsi qu'au Conseil
départemental chef de fil de l'action
sociale
lorsque les travailleurs social sera
présent cette mission ne sera
naturellement assignée néanmoins si le
déploiement des intervenants sociaux en
commissariat et unité de gendarmerie
suite en cours est encore loin d'être
effectif dans tous les départements nous
nous sommes donc interrogés en
commission sur le bien-fondé de cette
disposition à l'évidence il ne s'agit
pas là de compétences naturelles au plus
si et gendarmes nous avons cependant
préservé cette possibilité de demander
l'avance à l'occasion du dépôt de
plainte nous savons tous que ne sera pas
suffisant une simple information aux
victimes quant à leurs droits les
personnes souvent dans des états
traumatiques ne seront pas si nombreuses
à aller d'elles-mêmes vers la CAF en
outre les situations contraintes dans
lesquelles elles se trouvent peuvent les
empêcher de se rendre comme elles le
souhaitent auprès d'un nouveau guichet
retardant alors le déclenchement de
l'aide le texte propose donc un
mécanisme nécessaire de disons entre
service de l'État et service sociaux la
disposition est appelée à une
application la mieux adaptée possible
grâce à des échanges informatisés et
formalisés dans des conventions locales
en outre un amendement de coordination
de la commission vous proposa de
permettre aux assistants d'enquête que
le projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur en tant que créer d'exercer
ses missions d'enregistrement et de
transmission de la demande d'aide
d'urgence voilà mes chers collègues le
dispositif que le présent texte en tant
établir le gouvernement annoncé par
ailleurs des mesures et notamment un
pack nouveau départ d'autres initiatives
locales fleurissent je pense à celle
menée par la cave du Var et le barreau
de Toulon pour orienter efficacement des
victimes de violences Portugal et mener
sous 48 heures un examen complet de
l'endroit à prestation légale nous ne
pouvons que nous réjouir que toutes ces
avancées aillent dans la même direction
le dispositif de cette proposition de
loi n'est donc ni concurrente ni
redondant il s'agit d'une opportunité de
compléter les dispositifs existants
d'aide aux victimes de violences
conjugales c'est pourquoi la Commission
a adopté la proposition de loi est
évident que l'expérimentation dans le
Nord pourra le cas échéant apporter des
voies d'amélioration en cours de navette
parlementaires par ailleurs elle lèvera
sans aucun doute les réserves
institutionnelles qui peuvent encore
être formulés c'était de monétaire
légale s'inscrira dans les
environnements déjà formés par les
acteurs de l'action sociale le texte est
en effet la liberté au pouvoir
réglementaire et aux parties prenant de
s'organiser au plus proche des besoins
de chaque département je vous remercie
pour votre attention
merci Madame la rapporteur la parole est
maintenant madame Isabelle Rome ministre
délégué chargé de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes de la diversité de
l'égalité des chances vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
monsieur le président
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
rapporteur madame la sénatrice Valérie
Letard mesdames les sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs
en préambule permettez-moi de vous
féliciter madame la sénatrice Valérie
Letard madame la rapporteur pour votre
mobilisation dans la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes grandes
causes des deux quinquennats du
président de la République je sais le
Sienna particulièrement engagé sur cette
question et votre proposition de loi a
d'ailleurs réuni de nombreuses coups
signatures de manière transpartisane
la lutte contre les violences conjugales
premier piliers de la Grande Cause s'est
traduit par plusieurs actions concrètes
fruits pour la plupart du Grenelle des
violences conjugales et du travail
conjoint du gouvernement et des
parlementaires c'est l'illustration que
nous avons sont tous collectivement sur
ce sujet qui dépasse largement les
clivages de tous ordres et c'est le
résultat aussi du ressaisissement
collectif qu'a opéré notre société ces
dernières années notamment grâce à la
vague me too qui a dû faire les sur le
monde nous ne pouvons que nous en
réjouir trop longtemps notre société n'a
pas écouté les victimes ne les a pas cru
les laissant souvent seuls face à
l'emprise abandonnée face au coup dans
un huis clos avec leur agresseur
depuis cinq ans nous n'avons eu de cesse
de renforcer les dispositifs pour les
protéger ou d'en créer de nouveaux je
pense par exemple au téléphone grave
danger aux ordonnances de protection ou
bracelet antirachement à la présence
renforcée des intervenants sociaux dans
les commissariats les gendarmerie à la
formation massive des policiers des
gendarmes des magistrats ainsi qu'aux
nombre de places d'hébergement
d'urgence qui a considérablement
progressé durant le précédent
quinquennat ce mouvement je compte bien
entendu le poursuivre la première
ministre a annoncé le 2 septembre
dernier quel président
un comité interministériel sur l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes que je
piloterais pour décliner la feuille de
route des 5 ans à venir c'est à dire un
programme un plan plus exactement un
plan gouvernemental égalité les femmes
hommes qui sera déclinés sur les cinq
ans
oui je partage tout à fait vos constats
il faut t'aider à sortir les femmes les
victimes à sortir de cette emprise
25 ans 30 ans de magistrature quelques
années de président de cours d'assise
j'ai pu trop souvent constater c'est
faux départ
lorsqu'une femme parvient un jour à
parler à révéler les faits souvent elle
reste encore complètement trop sous la
dépendance de son conjoint que ce soit
sur le plan financier comme sur le plan
psychologique et elle est amenée à
retourner et parfois c'est l'heure de
ces allers-retours que l'irréparable se
commet
j'ai eu aussi à travailler beaucoup avec
les associations tant comme magistrates
que comme haute fonctionnaire du
ministère de la Justice chargée
notamment de coordonner les travaux du
Grenelle pour le ministère de la Justice
donc oui les associations aussi pensent
qu'il faut agir vite et nous sommes tout
à fait d'accord sur les constats oui il
faut les aider il faut les aider à
sortir sur ces de ces emprise il faut
t'éviter à tout prix c'est faux départ
et c'est dans ce sens là que
la un pack effectivement nouveau départ
que vous avez
signalé sera expérimenté donc dans le
cadre du comité interministériel
s'agissant donc de votre texte donc il
vise à créer un dispositif d'aide
financière sous la forme d'une avance
financière qui serait versée par les
caisses allocations familiales aux
femmes victimes de violence il s'agit
d'un prêt sans intérêt qui pose la
question évidente du remboursement du
remboursement que devrait par la suite
effectuer ces femmes
la perspective du remboursement pourrait
être un frein à l'objectif poursuivi à
savoir sécuriser les femmes pour
qu'elles puissent décider à fuir et
c'est ainsi que pour répondre à cet
enjeu votre texte permet notamment à la
CAF via un mécanisme de subrogation de
se retourner contre l'auteur des
violences pour obtenir remboursement de
ces de ce prêt toutefois
a-t-elle dispositif se heurte néanmoins
en droit au principe de la subrogation
légale qui suppose que les créances
transmises soit de même nature et
répondent au même régime juridique en
effet l'avance ici octroyée par la CAF
est un prêt sans intérêt
de nature et de régime distincts des
indemnités octroyées par le tribunal
correctionnel en réparation du préjudice
subi par la victime de violence la mise
en oeuvre de ce dispositif serait donc
non seulement d'une particulière
complexité mais le remboursement par
l'auteur semble également très
hypothétique
de manière plus générale
l'autonomie financière est un volet
essentiel de l'aide que nous devons
apporter à ces femmes mais il n'est pas
le seul vous le savez les besoins de ces
femmes sont multiples logements aide
financière accès aux droits garde
d'enfants réinsertion professionnelle
accompagnement psychologique et l'esprit
du pack nouveau départ pas justement par
le développement d'une prise en charge
globale coordonnée prioritaire dans la
durée et individualisée nous allons avec
la première ministre lancée une
expérimentation sur plusieurs
territoires afin d'élaborer le
dispositif pour qu'il réponde le mieux
aux besoins des femmes avant de
généraliser un modèle de prise en charge
nous souhaitons y associer pleinement
les parlementaires et nous inspirer des
dispositifs qui fonctionnent sur leur
territoire j'aimerais d'ailleurs et vous
l'avez fait également madame le
rapporteur saluer plusieurs initiatives
développées par les caps sur les
territoires je pense par exemple à la
CAF de la Côte d'Or qui propose une aide
financière individuelle non remboursable
d'un montant maximal de 1500 euros au
victimes de violences conjugales ayant
au moins un enfant à charge encore à la
CAF du Var qui a signé un protocole avec
le barreau de Toulon pour prendre en
charge sous 48 heures toute victime de
violences conjugales à la demande de son
avocat une aide financière est en versée
aux victimes pour un relogement en
urgence la cave du Val-d'Oise qui
apporte des aides pour acquérir des
biens d'équipements ménagers ou mobilier
de première nécessité ou encore la CAF
de la somme qui finance une aide au
départ d'urgence d'un montant de 500
euros plus 200 par enfant versé aux
femmes victimes de violences conjugales
par les associations têtes de réseau
départemental il y a de nombreux autres
exemples j'allais dire bien heureusement
puisque cela montre une mobilisation
collective et un peu partout sur les
territoires
l'expérimentation qui va être lancée
dans votre département du Nord et qui a
inspiré votre proposition de loi madame
la sénatrice Valérie Létard est
intéressante elle peut être intégrée
dans les réflexions du gouvernement mais
elle doit être un autre avis enrichi
pour couvrir tous les besoins des femmes
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement émettra
un avis de sagesse et s'engage à
travailler en synergie avec les
parlementaires les collectivités et les
associations désireux d'agir
concrètement je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame Colette mélo pour
le groupe les indépendants pour 4
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
madame la rapporteur
Valérie l'État que je remercie pour
cette
PPS il est déçu sur lesquels nous devons
nous exprimer avec la plus grande
précaution c'est le cas des violences
conjugales parce qu'il s'agit d'une
situation où la violence s'immiste dans
l'intime ou l'amour s'abîme dans
l'horreur et dans la haine les
problématiques sont aussi complexes que
révoltantes mais cette précaution ne
doit pas nous empêcher d'agir bien au
contraire seulement il convient de
privilégier la voix du pragmatisme et à
celle de l'idéologie la mesure et
l'action plutôt que les condamnations à
l'emporte-pièce c'est pourquoi je tiens
à saluer l'initiative de notre collègue
Valérie Létard dont le travail répond
précisément à cette exigence le fait que
le dispositif de la proposition de loi
soit directement inspirée par une
expérimentation conduite par des acteurs
de terrain
ah de quoi nous rassurer à cet égard ces
acteurs de terrain qu'il s'agissent des
services sociaux de proximité ou des
associations de soutien en victimes des
violences conjugales tous ces acteurs
sont unanimes sur la question le soutien
aux victimes doit passer par une aide
d'urgence facilement accessible et
rapidement des caissable en effet comme
je le disais en préambule les victimes
des violences conjugales sont
particulièrement fragiles et précaires
puisqu'elle partage bien souvent le même
domicile et les mêmes revenus que leurs
bourreau en conséquence les victimes
n'ont aucun moyen d'échapper à ces
violences qui sévissent au sein du même
du foyer d'où le cercle vicieux de la
violence qui s'installe perniciusement
dans la normalité d'un couple où les
sévices d'abord isolés commencent à se
répéter puis à devenir de plus en plus
grave et puisque les victimes n'ont pas
les moyens de s'échapper c'est violences
finissent par se banaliser elles
deviennent régulières bien souvent
quotidienne bientôt les victimes ne
peuvent plus ni s'opposer ni même les
que faire face à cette banalisation du
mal que faire alors même que les
victimes sont parfois tendance à
occulter ou à nier les violences
qu'elles subissent parce qu'un lien
affective les unis encore à leur bureau
la proposition de loi que nous allons
examiner vice précisément à offrir à ses
victimes l'espoir d'une échappatoire en
prévoyant la possibilité de débloquer en
trois jours un pécule pour permettre à
la victime de se mettre à l'abri nous
apportons une réponse concrète pour
briser ce cercle vicieux de la violence
en commission j'ai fait part de
plusieurs interrogations relatives à la
sécurisation du dispositif notamment
pour ceux qui concerne les modalités de
versement de l'avance et de son
recouvrement je crois que les
amendements proposés par la rapporteur
ont contribué à renforcer le dispositif
les précisions apportées notamment pour
mieux définir les critères d'octroi
rendront le dispositif envisagé plus
efficace et plus opérant pour dire plus
clairement les choses c'est toute la
difficulté de ce dispositif qui doit
apporter une réponse rapide pour
subvenir à l'urgence d'une situation en
évitant à tout prix que l'irréparable ne
se produit si cet objectif qui nous
oblige à veiller en priorité à la
célérité du dispositif cela n'exclut pas
une forme de contrôle mais il est
nécessaire que ce contrôle intervienne
expose c'est-à-dire après le versement
de la de l'avance afin de ne pas
ralentir une procédure ou la mise à
l'abri d'une victime tient parfois à peu
de choses en conclusion je crois que le
travail en commission a amélioré une
initiative parlementaire de grande
qualité qui répond aux préoccupations
issues du terrain
nous avons proposé un amendement qui
vise à répondre à un angle mort de la
proposition de loi qui concerne le
versement par les mutuelles sociales
agricoles de cette avance je pense que
nous allons en reparler notre groupe Les
Indépendants soutient cette initiative
j'espère qu'elle sera largement adoptée
par le Parlement et rapidement mise à
neuf par le gouvernement je vous
remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant madame Mélanie
Vogel pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire pour 4 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues sujet un peu plus facile
aujourd'hui
45 ans apparaissait pour la première
fois les mots féminicites pas les
féminicides mais la manière de les
nommer violence conjugale grâce au
mouvement féministe il y a 31 ans été
créé le premier numéro d'appel d'Etat
anonyme pour les victimes de violence
conjugales il y a 6 ans démarrait le
premier décompte des féminicides en
France
il y a 5 ans mis tout libérer la parole
sur les violences sexuelles et notamment
les violences sexuelles au sein des
couples depuis des lois ont été votées
2014 2018-2020 pour tâcher de paliers à
nos manquements mais la France continue
à être un pays où les femmes meurent et
son victime de violence parce qu'elles
sont des femmes le décompte de nos
mortes est à 102 filles Médicis pour
2022 nous ne cessons de dire tous les
ans en novembre et en mars à toutes les
victimes de violence que nous les
croyons croire la parole est essentielle
mais encore faut-il pouvoir quand on est
cru partir de chez soi
fuir son congin violent et en avoir la
possibilité économique nous vivons
encore dans un monde où la réalité et
que dans les couples hétérosexuels la
majorité des hommes gagne plus d'argent
que leur conjointe l'écart de revenus
étant de 47% en faveur des hommes et cet
écart se creuse avec les séparations
conjugales le texte proposé par notre
collègue Valérie Letard en temps face à
cette état de fait permettant après à
destination des femmes victimes de
violence afin de leur permettre d'avoir
les moyens de partir de chez leur
conjoint violents et d'engager des
actions judiciaires
le principe d'un prêt c'est qu'il engage
à devoir être remboursé et
il peut paraître compliqué pour une
femme victime de violence de prendre un
prêt à taux zéro mais qu'elle devra
s'engager à rembourser en supposant
qu'elle en aura les moyens de plus si la
poursuite en justice de la victime
échoue et je rappelle que 80% des
plaintes pour violence conjugales sont
classées sans suite donc en l'état
actuel de la réalité de notre pays
vis-à-vis du traitement judiciaire des
violences conjugales ça a plus de 80% de
risque d'arrivée elle devra tout de même
soit exception rembourser le prêt et
puis même si la procédure aboutit sur
une condamnation la cave pourrait se
servir dans les dommages et intérêts
obtenus pour réparation de violence
dommage et intérêt qui ont vocation
normalement à réparer les préjudices
subis et auxquelles personne n'aurait
touché si cette personne avait eu les
moyens
je pense également aux Françaises qui
réside à l'étranger et qui me semble en
partie oubliée par ce texte et à qui
nous devons aussi la protection
celles et ceux dont la majorité ne sont
pas inscrites au registre des Français
de l'étranger on pour obligation dans ce
texte d'y être inscrit et de porter
plainte ou faire un signalement en
France ou dans le pays de résidence
tout le monde le sait peut-être pas mais
plus de la moitié des Françaises et des
Français qui vivent à l'étranger ne
s'inscrivent pas au consulat on peut
leur dire que c'est une erreur il
faudrait mieux s'inscrire mais dans les
faits ça exclut un grand nombre de
personnes je regrette que certains
inscriptions soient obligatoire puisque
c'est rarement quand on est victime de
violences conjugales qu'on se lance dans
des procédures administratives pour
s'inscrire au consulat
ceci étant dit le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire votera en faveur
de ce texte qui constitue malgré tout
une avancée
un pas très grand mais un pas dans la
bonne direction
en termes financière pour ces femmes
victimes de violence cette proposition
de loi de nos malgré tout pas faire
oublier tout le chemin qu'il reste à
parcourir en matière de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes en termes de
prévention de formation de moyens
financiers à louer à la mise en sécurité
des victimes et de leurs enfants à leur
reconstruction et la fin de l'impunité
et à la neutralisation des agresseurs en
attendant que mieux soit fait je vous
invite à ne pas oublier d'aller
manifester le 16 novembre avec nous
toutes contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles parce que c'est par la rue que
nous gagnions les combats merci chers
collègues
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant Monsieur Xavier
yakovelli pour le groupe RDPI pour 4
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame aministre
madame la rapporteur chers collègues
213000 c'est le nombre de femmes qui
déclarent avoir été victime de violences
conjugales physiques ou sexuelle par
leur conjoint ou ex-conjoint sur une
année les chiffres nous le savons sont
plus alarmants une femme meurt tous les
trois jours et demi sous les coups de
son mari ou de son ex-mari en 2020 en
2021 c'est 122 femmes et 21 hommes ces
violences touchent tous les territoires
elle touche toutes les catégories
sociales elles sont toujours lorsque
l'issue n'est pas mortelle source
d'isolement est devenue vulnérabilité
chez les victimes trop souvent livrées à
elles-mêmes seuls à la salle leur bureau
face au calvaire que vivent trop de trop
nombreuses victimes nous devons agir
agir en protégeant les personnes
victimes de violence conjugales c'est
ambition de la loi de 2010 que le
gouvernement sous la précédente
législature a renforcé et qui permet au
juge des affaires familiales de statuer
sur des mesures de protection sans que
la personne n'est déposée plainte le
nombre d'ordonnances nécessaires
d'augmenter depuis 2015 et il a même
doublé en 5 ans agir en éloignant le
conjoint violent car ça ne doit pas être
systématiquement la victime de quitter
le domicile c'est l'objectif du bracelet
anti rapprochement au dispositif de
surveillance électronique créée par la
loi du 28 décembre 2019 qui permet de
géolocaliser la victime et son agresseur
ce qui constitue l'une des mesures les
plus protectrices en matière de
violences conjugales je pense également
à l'instauration du référé violence
conjugale procédure qui permet au juge
d'ordonner l'éviction du conjoint
violent et l'attribution du domicile
conjugal à la
agir en apportant assistance aux
victimes en situation de vulnérabilité
et en grave danger c'est la raison pour
laquelle le dispositif téléphone grave
danger accessible 7 jours sur 7 et 24
heures sur 24 a été généralisé afin de
permettre à toutes les victimes de
violences conjugales d'y avoir un accès
à l'ensemble du territoire il permet
ainsi d’alerter et de faire intervenir
immédiatement les forces de l'ordre en
cas de menaces ou de violences graves à
la géolocalisation
un numéro unique le 39 19 a par ailleurs
été déployé et l'examen de cette
proposition de loi doit nous permettre
d'en faire la promotion à destination de
toutes les femmes victimes où en danger
agir enfin pour l'avenir des victimes et
c'est tout l'objet du pack nouveau
départ annoncé en septembre dernier par
la ministre et qui accompagnera les
victimes de violences de façon globale
grâce à la mobilisation d'aide sociale
de l'accès à la formation l'aide au
retour à l'emploi l'hébergement
d'urgence ou encore un soutien
psychologique et pourtant malgré ses
avancées salutaires et l'action du
gouvernement la situation est critique
chers collègues trop de femmes par peur
de se retrouver seul avec leur conjoint
violence s'enferme dans le déni parfois
la honte et renonce à porter plainte ou
à s'enfuir face à ces drames il est de
la responsabilité du législateur
d'apporter des solutions concrètes c'est
l'objet de cette proposition de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui et qui vise à
créer une aide universelle d'urgence
pour les victimes violences de violences
conjugales portées par la présidente
l'État et dont j'ai le plaisir d'être
cossignataire notre groupe en partage
l'objectif puisque le dispositif
permettra la victime de s'extraire avec
ses enfants d'une situation de danger en
lui apportant une aide garantissant son
autonomie financière car protéger la mer
c'est aussi protégé les enfants ses
enfants sont en effet les victimes
directes lorsqu'ils sont eux-mêmes
frappés ou menacés mais également
indirect lorsqu'ils sont tout simplement
exposés à ces violences ils sont par
ailleurs souvent instrumentalisés pour
maintenir une certaine emprise du
conjoint violent sur la victime les
études récentes montrent que les enfants
traumatisés par ces violences ont
davantage de problèmes de santé comme le
retard de croissance et présente 10 à 17
fois plus de troubles de comportement
que les enfants qui vivent dans un foyer
sans violence
nous sommes néanmoins sceptiques et on
en a parlé avec la présidente l'état
quant à la notion de prêt car le fait de
devoir rembourser ses têtes pour être
pour être pour de nombreux cas synonyme
d'insécurité chez les femmes victimes en
situation de précarité qui ont subirait
les effets sur le plan financier mais je
ne doute pas que la présidente l'état
nous apportera des réponses
complémentaires visant à pallier les
difficultés que ce dispositif pourrait
entraîner et bien
sans réserve notre groupe soutiendra
cette conversion de loi merci monsieur
la parole est maintenant à madame la
Présidente Rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste pour 6 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
Madame lotrice Cher Valérie léthard
madame la Présidente sociale et madame
n'a rapporteur et chers
discuter et d'initier un peu une
procédure législative qui nous
souhaitons aboutira et merci aussi de
d'initier dans votre département
la mise en œuvre expérimentation de ce
que vous proposez aujourd'hui dans un
point de vue de généraliser celles et
ceux d'entre nous qui ont déjà eu
l'occasion d'accompagner des victimes de
violence conjugales le savent l'un des
premiers écueils à la dénonciation des
violences subies c'est les conséquences
de la dénonciation et en particulier la
crainte de devoir quitter le domicile et
de se retrouver sans ressource dans une
précarité matérielle qui menace la
survie de l'écosystème mère enfant en
particulier puisque un truc quand il y a
des enfants et soyons clairs cette
crainte est suffisamment forte pour être
dissuasive et amener des femmes à rester
et vous savez tous ceux qui vous disent
mais on comprend pas pourquoi elle reste
on a tellement de réponses à leur donner
sur pourquoi elle reste c'est une c'est
un des aspects que vous nous proposez
traiter aujourd'hui parce que
l'indépendance économique est
indispensable à l'émancipation des
femmes d'ailleurs qu'elles soient ou non
victime de violence indépendance
économique est aussi une prévention
contre la survenance de violence
conjugales et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'avais par précédemment
défendu la décongivalisation de la
location de soutien familiale par
exemple ou l'augmentation du SMIC
pourquoi l'augmentation du SMIC parce
que
59,3% des smicards sont des smicardes et
que un SMIC bas c'est plus de femmes en
précarité
nous fêtons cette année les 50 mitos
grâce à tous les témoignages aux
mobilisations du mouvement féministe
mobilisation des associations
spécialisées au combat le combat contre
les violences conjugales et maintenant
un objet de politique publique qui
mobilise le gouvernement on peut trouver
que c'est passé mais on pourrait me
reconnaître et
identifier une mobilisation mais qui
n'avait pas commencé en 2017 qui date de
bien avant puisque moi-même j'ai défendu
le cinquième plan de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes plan
triennale donc si c'est un plan triennal
vous imaginez bien que tous les
gouvernements depuis 2007 ou 2008
c'était déjà engagé dans lutte contre
les violences mais aujourd'hui ce sujet
est un sujet de société partagée et
Madame la Ministre j'en profite pour
vous dire que le Grenelle c'était bien
mais qu'un plan est un ministériel de
lutte faisant suite et inscrivant dans
la continuité ce qui a été fait
précédemment serait également bienvenue
nous avons fait déjà mais il reste
encore à faire aussi bien sur le plan
légal que sur le plan matériel et
pratique il ne faudra il nous faudra
revoir les restrictions modalités
d'exercice d'autorité parentale et du
droit de visiter d'hébergement par les
auteurs de violence
l'exclusion de la résidence principale
de l'enfant chez l'auteur des violences
l'augmentation de la durée et la portée
de l'ordonnance de protection on peut
encore il y a des choses encore à
évoluer la question de la dissimulation
d'adresse de résidence et de l'école
d'enfants Alex conjoint violent et puis
le renforcement de la lutte contre les
violences ce poste séparation qui reste
encore un sujet je crois que le
calendrier parlementaire nous permettra
à l'avenir d'avancer sur ces différents
points et la mission parlementaire que
vous avez initié et pour laquelle vous
avez désigné une sénatrice et une
députée permettra au-delà de la question
des juridictions spécialisées j'imagine
de balayer l'ensemble des vide juridique
des trous dans la raquette pardonnez-moi
la trivialité de l'expression qui reste
encore
la création d'une aide financière
d'urgence telle que vous la proposez
madame l'autrice monsieur Valérie Létard
et
est indispensable aujourd'hui c'est un
moyen immédiatement mobilisable pour
faciliter la sortie des violences
j'ajoute que la CNAF est en excédent
budgétaire cette année nous aurions
bientôt de d'hésiter à le faire et à le
voter et grâce à un amendement porté par
ma collègue victoire jasmin et au nom du
groupe socialiste est prévu la
demi-philiation de droits des victimes
de violence auprès d'un CCAS ou d'un
CCIS ou d'un organisme à créer si elle
le demande
et puis je voudrais chers collègues en
quelque sorte et sous forme de
conclusion ajouter que cette
mobilisation financière nouvelle qui
effectivement est un effort de la
collectivité publique par
l'intermédiaire de la location familiale
et presque injuste retour des choses je
vous suggère la lecture de l'ouvrage de
Lucile petavin qui s'appelle le coût de
la virilité et qui souligne à quel point
la violence masculine est omniprésente
et très coûteuse dans notre société et
je la cite elle dit qu'en France les
comportements virils masculins sont
responsables chaque année de 7 milliards
sur les 9,06 milliards d'euros du budget
total de la justice de 8,6 milliards sur
les 13 milliards du budget total des
forces de l'ordre de 2,3 milliards sur
les 16 milliards du budget total des
urgences et des hospitalisations qui
sont suivent et à cela il faut ajouter
le coût humain et social de ces
infractions à la loi puisqu'il y a
derrière ces actes des vies des vies
brisées
plus de 200 000 femmes sont victimes
chaque année de violences de la part de
leur conjoint ou ex-conjoints sur la
totalité des violences conjugales 96%
des auteurs sont des hommes ce qui
représente pour nos finances publiques
un coup de 3,3 milliards d'euros donc on
regarde de ce que nous coûte la violence
masculine les budgets que nous propose
de mobiliser Valérie Létard et qui
seront des budgets appelés à être
restitués puisque sont des avances
surpris par les caisses d'allocations
familiales sont bien minuscules enfin en
proposant de créer cette aide financière
la proposition de loi va dans le bon
sens celle du soutien aux victimes et le
groupe écologiste socialiste écologiste
et républicains que je représente à cet
instant la soutiendra avec enthousiasme
merci
merci madame la Présidente la parole est
maintenant madame Michel greyom pour le
groupe CRCE pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame le rapporteur mes chers collègues
le sujet des violences conjugales
revient régulièrement dans notre
assemblée et force est de constater
qu'il reste beaucoup à faire pour
éradiquer le mâle qui ronge notre
société le nord et le deuxième
département de France métropolitaine le
plus touché c'est dire si Valérie Létard
et moi connaissons bien la problématique
une réalité locale qui rejoint les
statistiques nationales des violences
faites aux femmes en 2019 selon
l'Observatoire national des violences
faites aux femmes 213
000 femmes ont été victimes de violences
physiques et sexuelle commise par leur
partenaire ou ex partenaire
selon le bilan du ministère de
l'Intérieur parut cet été le nombre de
féminicides à augmenter de 20% en 2021
par rapport à l'année précédente 122 de
nos soeurs nos mères nos cousines nos
voisines nos filles sont décédées sous
les coups d'un conjoint ou Aix ce
conjoint contre 102 en 2020 ce qui
retient les femmes de quitter le
domicile conjugal outre l'emprise
exercée par le conjoint c'est le manque
de ressources financières en effet il
est fréquent que les victimes n'est pas
accès aux comptes bancaire du foyer ou
qu'elle n'est pas de source de revenus
personnel
le départ est alors synonyme de
difficulté à assurer pour elle et pour
leur enfant les achats de première
nécessité
très souvent ces difficultés contribuent
à un retour contrat au domicile conjugal
la mise en place d'une aide financière
d'urgence aux victimes permettra
d'encourager cette démarche de départ
salvatrice j'avais moi-même formulé
cette proposition dans un texte déposé
en février 2021
consistant en l'attribution du RSA en
urgence aux victimes de violence ATRA
familiales
ce dispositif sera d'ailleurs
expérimenté dès le mois prochain dans
mon arrondissement du Valenciennois à
l'initiative du département du Nord
on pourra au passage regretter que
l'évaluation de cette expérience n'est
pas été attendue avant de débattre d'un
dispositif alternatif
dans le texte qui nous est soumis l'aide
pour la forme d'après accordé par les
Caisses d'Allocations Familiales
déclenchées dans un délai porté à trois
jours ouvrés par la Commission et versée
en trois mensualités les modifications
apportées par la Commission ont permis
de cadrer les conditions d'accès à cette
aide sans qu'elle ne soit trop
restrictive et nous devons la remercier
et féliciter le travail de la sénatrice
guidée en tant que rapporteur de ce
texte ce principe de soutien au départ
d'urgence n'a pas vocation à remettre en
cause le principe d'éloignement des
auteurs des violences
ni à résoudre à lui seul l'ensemble de
la problématique des violences faites
aux femmes je raconte je rappelle que
les associations féministes demandent un
investissement massif à hauteur d'un
milliard d'euros afin d'engager une
véritable lutte efficace contre les
violences faites aux femmes et aux
enfants dans l'esprit de la Grande Cause
Nationale décrétée et annoncée par le
président de la République à l'aube de
son précédent mandat
la prévention et la protection des
femmes et des enfants victimes de
violentes de violences sont également
indispensables pour éviter que ces
comportements ne se reproduisent de
générations en génération
néanmoins il s'agit d'un premier pas
pour accompagner les victimes de
violences conjugales qui doit être
saluée avec cette proposition de loi le
Sénat l'occasion d'envoyer un signal en
montrant que nous sommes capables de
nous réunir et de dépasser nos
divergences partisanes pour lutter
contre les violences conjugales pour
cette raison le groupe CRCE votera en
faveur de ce texte modifié par la
commission je vous en remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Annick jacquemais pour
le groupe Union centriste pour 6 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
rapporteur cher Valérie
et chers collègues
5 ans que Mitou a libéré la parole des
femmes
cinq ans qu'avec courage elles sont
enfin sorties du silence qu'elles ont
bravé le sentiment de honte qui trop
souvent les enferme dans un carcan de
culpabilité
les témoignages se sont multipliés dans
toutes les couches de la société
révélant au grand jour des violons
jusque-là insoupçonnés ou ignoré
les victimes se sont mises à parler et
la société à les écouter enfin nous
avons pris conscience de ce fléau une
véritable révolution
les violences conjugales sont un
phénomène multiforme complexe qui nous
revient de traiter dans sa globalité
elles peuvent être physiques
psychologiques mais aussi économique et
se traduisent dans les faits par une
précarité telle que la victime ne peut
survivre sans son agresseur chantage
financier confiscation des ressources
financières ou des moyens de paiement
ces comportements visa acculer la
victime et la pousser à des
surendettements personnels 19% des
femmes déclarent subir des violences
économiques lorsqu'elles font appel au
numéro d'aide aux victimes
selon le ministère de l'Intérieur les
plaintes pour violences conjugales
atteignaient en 2020 le nombre de
159400 en hausse depuis quelques années
alors qu'une enquête statistique du
ministère estime à 295000 le nombre
annuel de victimes de violences
conjugales dont 72% de femmes et 28%
d'hommes il ne faut pas les oublier en
2021 122 femmes ont été tuées par un
conjoint ou en ancien conjoint soit une
hausse de 20% par rapport à 2020
j'ajoute qu'une étude de Liné de
l'Institut national d'études
démographiques de 2018 réveil que près
d'une femme sur cinq se déclare en
situation de violence conjugale en
Martinique et en Guadeloupe
un certain nombre de mesures ont déjà
été prises ou renforcées le téléphone
grave danger il y en a plus de 4000 le
39 19 joignable sans interruption depuis
le 30 août 2021 la messagerie
instantanée qui permet de dialoguer avec
un agent de police les plus de 9000
places d'hébergement avec les 1000
nouvelles décidés en début d'année les
ordonnances de protection prises par un
juge aux affaires familiales qui
prononce l'éloignement du conjoint
violent et permet dans le même temps
d'organiser la vie de famille les
bracelets anti rapprochement et aussi
les centres de prise en charge des
auteurs de violence pour éviter les
récidives
malgré ses avancées les données
issues des appels au numéro 39 19
violences femmes à faux montrent que 59%
des victimes souhaitent quitter le
domicile conjugal 18% d'entre elles
indiquent avoir effectué plusieurs
départs pour revenir au foyer faute de
moyens financiers permettant le
autonomie
il leur est donc très difficile de
réussir à couper définitivement les
ponts avec leur torsionnaire d'autant
plus lorsqu'elle partent avec leurs
enfants
l'aide financière d'urgence doit donc
s'imposer comme un des piliers de prise
en charge et d'accompagnement des
victimes de violences conjugales c'est
une mesure de bon sens qui émane du
terrain de celles et ceux qui
travaillent au quotidien avec ses
victimes services sociaux du département
CAF parquet association
et pour été pour avoir été en charge des
solidarités dans mon département du
Doubs cette PPL cher Valérie et la
bienvenue
quelques éléments de la proposition de
loi me semble importante nous savons
qu'au-delà de 72 heures les victimes
livrées à elle-même sont contraintes de
rentrer au domicile ce dispositif répond
à ce besoin en versant dans un délai
maximum de trois jours une somme dans le
montant sera fixée par décret cette aide
n'étant pas une allocation mais bien
prêt à taux zéro il devrait être
remboursé dans son intégralité selon un
échéancier variable mais la proposition
de loi propose aussi un mécanisme
permettant à la cave de se constituer
partie civile cela lui permettra si le
prêt est encore en cours au moment du
jugement de ce rembourser sur les
dommages et intérêts versés par le
coupable enfin c'était des universel et
je pense qu'à ce niveau d'urgence il n'y
a pas lieu de faire une quelconque
distinction entre milieu sociaux
nous connaissons tous le taux de non
recours aux aides sociales et c'est pour
cette raison qu'il incombera à
l'officier à l'agent de police
judiciaire ou à l'intervenant social en
commissariat et gendarmerie recevant la
victime de l'informer de l'existence de
ce prêt dans n'enregistrer la demande et
de la transmettre à la CAF ainsi qu'aux
conseils départemental chef de file de
l'action sociale cela demandera une
parfaite information et formation de
ceux qui sont souvent en première ligne
pour accueillir les victimes
je terminerai mon propos en soulignant
le travail formidable fait par tous les
partenaires dans toutes les associations
d'aide aux victimes de violences
conjugales souvent confrontées à des
difficultés financières et je garde en
mémoire la lueur d'espoir qui se rallume
dans les yeux de celles qui sont prises
en charge et accompagnées pour se
reconstruire qui voit enfin leur avenir
s'éclaircir je voudrais remercier
chaleureusement nos collègues Valérie
léthard pour avoir travaillé sur le
terrain dans son département du Nord et
concrétiser ce dispositif Sud utile
ainsi que Jocelyne guidez pour son
travail consciencieux et sérieux de
rapporteur qui a amendaient ce texte
avec précision je suis persuadée que
cette proposition de loi permettra de
faire un bon en avant dans la lutte
contre les violences conjugales et
pourra éviter bien des drames en offrant
une échappatoire aux victimes le groupe
l'union du centre votre évidemment en
faveur de ce texte je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant madame Esther
Benbassa pour les non inscrits pour 3
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la rapporteur cher Valérie l'état
chers
et les hommes je cite l'autonomie
financière est une condition pour
reprendre sa vie en main à fortiori
lorsqu'il s'agit des femmes victimes de
violence conjugales je vais prendre sa
vie en main est un long parcours il faut
d'abord qu'elle soit écoutée et
comprennent en considération ce qu'elle
disent les mots et les souffrances qui
les accompagnent elle cherche aussi une
protection pour enfants
envisagée de se reconstruire la mise en
place de cette avance d'urgence pour les
victimes de violence conjugales incite
un emprunter cette voix si difficile
soit elle une pierre qui s'ajoute à la
construction d'une culture de la
protection si défaillante actuellement
pour plus de 350 000 interventions les
forces de l'ordre au domicile des
familles seuls 79000 procès-verbaux de
renseignements judiciaires et main
courante ont été déposés en 2019 la
faille réside dans cet écart s'il y
avait eu une prise en charge à temps on
aurait pu éviter quelques victimes mardi
j'ai rencontré Aïcha dans les locaux du
foyer Louise Labé géré par l'association
halte aux femmes battues un centre
d'hébergement spécialisé voici son
témoignage je cite mon mari me frappait
il me disait maintenant que tu n'as plus
de famille je veux je fais ce que je
veux de toi alors un jour je suis partie
avec un bébé dans le ventre un dans les
bras mais claquettes et rien d'autre
pendant deux ans je n'ai pu toucher
aucune aide fin de citation
conjointement la colère des femmes dont
les signalements ne sont pas toujours
entendus il
[Musique]
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Eric gold pour le
groupe RDSE pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame le rapporteur cher collègue
difficile de ne pas partager l'ambition
de cette proposition de loi déposée par
notre collègue Valérie Letard qui a eu
l'amabilité de nous inviter à la
coussinie ce que plusieurs d'entre nous
ont fait au sein du groupe RDSE
143 victimes de mort violente au sein du
couple en 2021 dont 122 femmes 2022 ne
semble malheureusement pas marquée de
recul ce qui a sans doute poussé le
président de la République a déclaré la
grande grande cause nationale du
quinquennat pour la deuxième fois la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes le sujet a d'ailleurs fait la une
des médias récemment prouvant une fois
de plus qu'aucun milieu n'était épargné
par la violence et que parmi les hommes
politiques certains avaient encore un
long chemin à parcourir sur la question
poussée par la société civile de
nombreuses activistes les pouvoirs
publics tentent avec des moyens et des
résultats encore insuffisants de réduire
la violence au sein du couple le
Grenelle contre les violences conjugales
de 2019 a accouché de 54 mesures dont 46
sont aujourd'hui en vigueur des outils
existent comme le téléphone grave danger
ou le bracelet anti rapprochement
assorti d'un budget à la hauteur et
accompagné de mesures telles qu'une
formation adaptée des forces de l'ordre
ou l'éducation à la vie effective et
sexuelle dès le plus jeune âge nous
pouvons espérer que la situation
s'améliore dans les années à venir
dans l'immédiat et afin de compléter
l'arsenal aujourd'hui disponible l'objet
de cette proposition de loi vise à
répondre à une problématique récurrente
pour les victimes de violences
conjugales la dépendance financière
elles sont en effet nombreuses à
demeurer ou à retourner au domicile
conjugal faute de ressources de
ressources suffisantes notamment
lorsqu'elles ont des enfants à charge
qu'elle refuse naturellement de laisser
derrière elle
les aides
telles que le RSA
lorsqu'elles lorsqu'elles sont éligibles
nécessitent un délai souvent
rédhibitoire
il est donc proposé ici de donner les
moyens financiers aux victimes de
s'extirper d'un environnement violent
alors accordant une aide d'urgence sous
forme d'un prêt à taux zéro délivrez-la
par la CAF en trois mensualités dont la
première octroyée sous trois jours
cette avance est conditionnée à une
ordonnance de protection délivrée par le
juge un dépôt de plainte de la victime
ou un signalement d'un professionnel de
santé adressé au procureur elle pourra
être récupérée par la CAF directement
auprès de l'auteur des violences si
cette dernière se constitue partie
civile
pour demander au nom de la victime la
réparation de la créance sur les
dommages et intérêts prononcés
la victime n'aurait alors plus à
rembourser le prêt
la proposition de loi prévoit par
ailleurs que les allocataires de
l'avance bénéficient automatiquement des
droits accessoires à la prestation du
RSA comme la complémentaire santé ou les
droits décidés par les collectivités
telles que le tarif réduit pour les
transports en commun mais cette aide
n'est pas pour autant conditionnée à un
accès au RSA ce qui la rend universel
la proposition de loi s'appuie sur une
expérimentation menée par le département
du Nord la CAF le parquet et d'autres
acteurs notamment à sa associatif
cette expérience sera particulièrement
utile à sa généralisation une
généralisation souhaitable voire
indispensable en ce qu'elle crée un
droit supplémentaire sur la question
hautement sensible de la dépendance
financière pour laquelle les auteurs de
violence ne manquent pas de ressources
le chantage financier et la confiscation
des moyens de paiement sont fréquents
ils aggravent le climat de violence
restreignent le champ de liberté des
victimes et les éloigne de la
perspective d'une suite pourtant vitale
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe RDSE
votera d'une seule voix pour cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie
si chers collègues la parole et
maintenant madame Alexandra borquio
fontin du groupe les républicain pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
que répondre aux victimes de violence
dont certaines hélas ne peuvent même
plus nous entendre en tout état de cause
tous les mots prononcés dans cette
hémicycle ici est maintenant
n'apaiseront en rien la douleur des
cours répétés d'un conjoint violent
espérons que ce débat puisse néanmoins
faire évoluer la cause des femmes et des
hommes victimes de violences conjugales
afin que la peur change de camp une
bonne fois pour toute qu'un véritable
cadre protecteur et rassurant pour les
victimes soit enfin mise en place afin
qu'elles se sont plus seuls et
abandonnés à leur sort et qu'elle garde
ce qu'elles ont de plus précieux leur
liberté et leur dignité alors le ton
doit être humble la volonté politique
ambitieuse réunie pour examiner ce texte
défendu par notre collègue Valérie
léthard nous ne pouvons que féliciter sa
proposition qui va dans le bon sens
rendre aux victimes de violences
conjugales une indépendance financière
conditions sine qua non pour qu'elle se
libère enfin des de l'angoisse de la
violence fruit d'un consensus
transpartisan s'est avec honneur que
j'en défends donc la teneur et en
réaffirme la qualité le Sénat s'est
saisi depuis de nombreuses années de ce
fléau et demeure une source inépuisable
de propositions lorsqu'il s'agit
d'introduire des mesures efficaces et
protectrices envers les victimes de
violences conjugales le récent rapport
sur les zones blanches de l'égalité doit
appeler toute l'attention du
gouvernement sur la particularité
notamment des zones rurales qui
apparaissent malheureusement comme des
Terreaux intarissables de féminicides si
des moyens supplémentaires sont engagés
pour endiguer cette effroyable fléau il
nous revient de veiller avec beaucoup de
vigilance à ce qu'ils puissent donc
bénéficier à toutes et tous de façon
égalitaire et ce aux quatre coins de
l'hexagone et des Outre-mer l'égalité
entre les êtres se plébiscitent de tous
les jours passe aussi par une égalité
entre les territoires nous devons donc
collectivement revoir notre copie pour
que personne ne soit laissé sur le bord
de la route
à 36 jours de la Journée internationale
pour l'élimination des violences à
l'égard des femmes affirmont d'abord
notre reconnaissance admiration à celle
qui ont trouvé les ressources pour
demander de l'aide entamer un processus
de reconstruction et témoigné
osons clamer enfin car il le faut que le
combat pour l'égalité est une lutte de
tous les instants une bataille
permanente et que le moindre relâchement
nous est interdit alors que les
Françaises et les Français des contront
les heures avant le passage en 2023
d'autres procéderont déjà au décomptes
des femmes lâchement assassinées sous
les coups de leur conjoint ou
ex-conjoint le 1er janvier dernier
Muriel Lisa et Éléonore ouvraient se bal
funeste illustrer les dysfonctionnements
dramatiques de notre système judiciaire
nous devons enfin comprendre que la
non-assistance à personne en danger ne
peut plus durer preuve en est un rapport
de l'Inspection générale de la justice
en 2019 sur les homicides conjugaux qui
indiquent que si 41% avaient alerté les
forces de sécurité 82% des mains ont été
procès-verbaux de renseignements
judiciaires n'avaient donné lieu à
aucune investigation tandis que 80% des
plaintes avaient abouti à un classement
sans suite avant d'envisager d'autres
réformes il est urgent pour celles qui
sont encore en vie d'appliquer les lois
existantes la responsabilité
individuelle ne doit pas se diluer dans
la responsabilité collective la parole
politique la loi et la justice sont le
pouvoir de remettre ce monde à l'endroit
ce monde où la victime a trop longtemps
été la coupable et puis il nous faut
penser au futur ne pas hypothéquer la
liberté de nos filles et de nos fils en
laissant se perpétrer la violence devant
eux parce que ne pas stopper la violence
est en engager une reproduction
mécanique à l'égard de la génération
suivante comment ignorer qu'un enfant
témoin présente quatre fois plus de
chances de devenir auteur de violence
conjugales les six fois plus de chance
de devenir victime les études démontrent
qu'il subissent des traumatismes
comparables à ceux que les personnes
confrontées à la guerre développe
comment tolérer encore en 22 une telle
destruction de l'enfance il y a donc
urgence à agir sur les plans de la
détection de la prise en charge de la
protection des victimes de violence tout
en s'assurant de la mise hors d'état de
nuire des personnes violentes il est
urgent de protéger soutenir et
accompagner celles qui sont chaque jour
humiliés et ce les volonté merci cher
collègue Valérie Létard grâce à vos
travaux et au dispositions de cette
proposition de loi de contribuer à un
meilleur accompagnement des victimes
au-delà des avancées incontestables la
protection des victimes face aux
violences doit rester une priorité
collective le travail ne s'achèvera
jamais tant qu'il y aura des êtres
atteints de cette folie de suprémacie
sur l'autre avec comme seul arme
d'affirmation la violence poursuivons
tous ensemble ce grand chantier au
combien majeur pour l'humanité je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Madame elsachalke pour le
groupe les républicains pour 5 minutes
dernier oratrice
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la rapporteur madame la
Présidente de commission madame la
sénatrice Valérie léthard mes chers
collègues comment dans notre pays
pouvons-nous contrer ce véritable fléau
que constitue les violences conjugales
cette question nous l'évoquons
régulièrement au sein de cette émission
tant le sujet est majeur complexe et
revêt plusieurs réalités un constat est
unanime seule une mobilisation
collective de tous les acteurs de la
société permettra d'y arriver je
souhaite ce matin rappeler trois
chiffres les violences conjugales ont
augmenté de 20% en 2021
87% des victimes de violence sont des
femmes mais seulement 3% des victimes de
violence avaient porté plainte en 2020
en février dernier nous débattions ici
même des mesures issues du Grenelle des
violences de 2019 nous mettions alors en
évidence l'importance d'une réponse
judiciaire rapide et efficace mais
également la question de la
sensibilisation de la formation des
professionnels ainsi que le sujet au
combien essentiel de l'accompagnement
des victimes qui regroupent de nombreux
aspects notamment social psychologique
mais également économique même si le
principe premier doit être l'éviction de
l'auteur des violences il convient de
rappeler que 59% des victimes souhaitent
quitter le domicile avec une réalité qui
s'impose à nous et qui ressort des
témoignages des victimes sans argent on
ne part pas la dépendance économique de
certaines femmes demeurent actuellement
un des freins pour quitter le domicile
conjugal par ailleurs les économique qui
peuvent passer du contrôle financier
jusqu'à la dépossession totale des
moyens financiers sont souvent
invincibles et mal identifié ce type de
violence qui font partie intégrante des
violences conjugales mériteraient
d'ailleurs d'être clairement défini dans
notre droit interne il est indispensable
que les victimes puissent faire
confiance aux institutions et qu'elles
puissent trouver rencontrer parler avec
des interlocuteurs de proximité et il
nous appartient à nous législateurs de
faciliter et de sécuriser au mieux leur
parcours en cela je salue aujourd'hui
cette proposition de loi est le travail
mené par notre collègue Valérie Letard
instaurer une aide universelle d'urgence
pour les victimes de violences
conjugales c'est tout simplement une
réponse concrète c'est une réponse qui
peut se mettre rapidement en place et
c'est une réponse à besoin
identifier
cette aide financière viendra ainsi
compléter des initiatives locales et ça
a été rappelé lors du débat qui ont
émergé pour permettre d'accompagner
justement les victimes sur le plan
matériel je cite pour exemple
l'association d'aide aux victimes viaduc
77 dans le Bas-Rhin qui distribue des
produits de première nécessité aux
femmes ayant quitté leur domicile
je tiens à saluer le principe même de
cette aide d'urgence qui prendra la
forme d'un prêt financier sans intérêt
versé par les Caisses d'Allocations
Familiales je salue également les
modalités qui ont été envisagées par le
texte et que le travail parlementaire a
permis d'enrichir le mécanisme de
subrogation des cafs dans les droits des
victimes pour demander réparation du
préjudice subi et faire payer l'auteur
des violences me paraît tout à fait
pertinent tout comme l'information de la
victime dès son dépôt de plainte prévue
à l'article 2 de ce texte il s'agit là
d'une condition nécessaire pour que
l'aide d'urgence puisse être effective
tout comme d'ailleurs la rapidité de la
mise en œuvre du prêt qui est
indispensable pour que le dispositif
puisse fonctionner
comme le souligne également le rapport
cette aide d'urgence devra s'accompagner
par le déploiement d'intervenants
sociaux au commissariat et unité de
gendarmerie nous convergeons ici vers un
constat que nous avions déjà établi au
moment du Grenelle du besoin des moyens
humains au plus près des territoires et
notamment dans la ruralité pour pouvoir
combattre efficacement les violences
conjugales je tiens enfin à saluer le
fait que cette proposition de loi est le
fruit d'expérimentation de terrain
inspiré par des initiatives locales il
s'agit là à mon sens de la meilleure
manière de légiférer
utilement et de manière pragmatique à ce
titre je remercie le travail mené
quotidiennement sur le terrain par les
acteurs locaux associations élus locaux
parquet service de police et de
gendarmerie
notre message collectif est clair
inciter les femmes à porter plainte les
encourager à dénoncer l'inacceptable et
leur permettre de quitter le domicile
étape souvent très délicate notamment
lorsqu'il y a des enfants pour toutes
ces raisons évoquées le groupe les
républicains salut ce texte et votre
bien évidemment sa faveur
merci chers collègues
la discussion générale est close nous
allons passer à la discussion du texte
de la commission
trois articles quatre amendements à
l'article premier je suis saisi de
quatre demandes de parole madame Michel
gréaume d'abord
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues l'article
premier poste des conditions d'accès les
modalités d'attribution de l'aide
d'urgence aux victimes de violence
conjugales il est ainsi précisé que la
personne bénéficiaire de l'aide
d'urgence peut se prévaloir dans les six
mois à compter du versement de la
première mensualité de la qualité de
bénéficiaires du revenu de solidarité
active y compris l'accompagnement social
et professionnel mentionnés à l'article
l262-27 dans sa première mouture le
texte ne prévoyait pas d'inclure cette
disposition qui est pourtant
automatiquement proposé aux
bénéficiaires du RSA d'aujourd'hui je me
félicite donc que la Commission est
ajoutée cette précision qui figurait
d'ailleurs dans le texte de ma
proposition de loi relative à une aide
financière d'urgence en direction des
victimes de violences conjugales
déposées en 2021
c'est les départements qui a déjà la
charge de cette prise en charge pour les
bénéficiaires du RSA qui consiste en une
démarche d'accompagnement qui prend en
compte la situation globale de la
personne et ses besoins formation santé
logement à tel dispositif proposé aux
victimes de violences conjugales
pourraient permettre de limiter le
risque d'un retour contrat au domicile
conjugal en favorisant l'accès à
l'emploi et à une autonomie financière
il me semblait important de souligner
l'intérêt de cet ajout de la commission
je vous en remercie
merci la parole est maintenant madame la
Présidente l'État
[Musique]
la commission des affaires sociales et
sa rapporteur d'avoir
enrichi effectivement cet article
premier
d'une disposition supplémentaire pour
effectivement entrer dans le dispositif
qui est celle du signalement après en
avoir échangé effectivement avec Madame
la rapporteur et Madame la rapporteur je
sais que vous avez entendu ceux qui
portent dans les services cette
expérimentation des choses sont en train
de se mettre en place avec le centre
hospitalier par exemple ou avec les
services sociaux qui justifient
maintenant que vu l'avancée du travail
tout cela soit possible et soit intégré
dans le dispositif ce qui n'était pas
encore évident au moment où on a écrit
ce texte par ailleurs aussi dire à nos
collègues et à ma collègue Michel
gréaume que si évidemment elle a
travaillé et elle travaillait encore
effectivement aux questions d'emprise
financières si nous avons fait le choix
d'une autre direction que celle de
l'avant sur droit supposé pour les
bénéficiaires du RSA c'est tout
simplement parce qu'on voyait
universalité indispensable à l'aide
qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre il faut que
il n'y ait pas que les femmes victimes
de violence bénéficiaires du RSA qui
souhaite toucher mais au travers de
cette aide universelle de ce près
d'honneur on permet à une femme qui
travaille mais qui n'a pas l'accès par
exemple à son compte bancaire et à son
propre salaire puis son bénéficier
qu'une jeune de moins de 25 ans puisse y
avoir accès aussi ou un retraité
l'intérêt de ce prêt donneur de la CAF
plutôt que l'avance sur RSA puisqu'il
s'agissait de l'avance sur RSA change
complètement la donnée de ce sujet je
voulais le rappeler dire bien sûr aussi
que à Madame la Ministre pourquoi il est
important de ne pas perdre de temps et
plutôt que de renvoyer effectivement à
des dates ou à des expérimentations
futures il faut se nourrir de
l'expérimentation qui dort déjà lancé
cette expérimentation elle a
effectivement le mérite de pouvoir être
dans le cas de la navette parlementaire
un élément sur lequel vous et vous
appuyez pour terminer le travail mais
s'il vous plaît ne perdons pas de temps
chaque jour compte
merci chers collègues alors c'est réglé
merci Madame Gwen la parole est à Madame
Laurence Cohen
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement je pense que cette
proposition de loi et est une étape un
petit pas en avant et c'est important
quand on sait qu'effectivement les
violences conjugales sont systémiques et
qu'elle touche absolument tous les
milieux donc c'est important qu'il y ait
ce genre de dispositif et comme l'ont
annoncé à la fois Valérie Letare et
Michel gréaume l'expérimentation au
niveau du département du Nord et quelque
chose d'intéressant un point d'appui
mais en même temps madame la ministre
vous le savez je veux attirer votre
attention c'est à dire que on voit que
face aux violences
intrafamiliales il y a eu effectivement
des avancées il y a eu des votes de d'un
certain nombre de propositions mais ce
sont des des lois qui sont finalement
cloisonnées et moi je veux vraiment je
plaise madame la ministre avec les
associations féministes pour que nous
puissions enfin pouvoir adopter une loi
4 contre les violences c'est la seule
façon pour arriver à vraiment
débarrasser la société de de ce fléau je
sais que vous y êtes sensible mais je
pense qu'il faut vraiment se retrouver
les manches et il parvenir donc tant que
il y a besoin aussi donc d'acte de ce
genre là il y a besoin aussi de moyens
humains et financiers là encore le
rapport de nos collègues Eric Bocquet
Arnaud Bazin de juillet 2020 marque bien
que le milliard n'y est pas or c'est une
revendication que je soutiens avec les
féministes pour combattre les violences
il faut des moyens humains et financiers
d'ailleurs tout dernièrement la la
fédération nationale solidarité femme
39-19 appelle au secours tellement elle
reçoivent des des appels de femmes en
détresse et qu'elle n'arrive plus à Hay
y répondre donc voilà je voulais marquer
ça à cette étape de notre de notre
la réflexion de notre débat et attirer
votre attention madame la mini je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Madame Victoire jasmin
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur et chers
Valérie l'état merci je renouvelle sur
merciment parce que chaque pas compte je
suis vraiment très heureuse de savoir
également que l'amendement que j'ai
proposé a été intégrée ça correspond à
véritable besoin c'est une urgence donc
j'ai bien entendu les remarques de la
plupart des collègues mais je crois que
nous devons aujourd'hui collectivement
prendre en compte les problématiques qui
se posent parce que malgré les
différentes
possibilités qu'il y avait déjà grâce
aux différents gouvernements au
gouvernement successifs qui ont chaque
fois permis de faire évoluer la
législation et bien on se rend compte
qu'il y a un contrôle de féminicides
trop de violences faites aux femmes et
les conséquences sur la société sur les
enfants sur l'ensemble de nos
territoires donc il est important que
nous puissions aujourd'hui voter et là
je l'ai bien compris que nous sommes
vraiment unan à reconnaître que c'est
nécessaire madame la ministre bien
entendu également les propositions et
les suggestions que vous avez faites
pour poursuivre donc je souhaite
vraiment que cela aille très vite et que
toutes les mesures qui seront prises par
votre gouvernement pourront permettre
désormais à des femmes et surtout à des
enfants d'être dans de meilleures
conditions pour éviter également les
rues saisies à ce niveau là aussi parce
que très souvent les enfants qui sont
dans ces milieux là et bien ce sont ces
enfants là qui demain seront les auteurs
et ce serait regrettable donc je
souhaite vraiment que nous puissions
tous collectivement faire progresser la
législation mais aussi prendre toutes
les mesures de prévention pour éviter le
pire je vous remercie
merci chers collègues nous passons à
l'amendement numéro 1 de Madame Benbassa
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement s'inscrit dans la philosophie
de ce texte qui était le foyer et l'une
des décisions les plus difficiles le
retour quant à lui reste parfois
inévitable
cette proposition de loi encourage à
prendre l'initiative de la demande nous
devons également nous assurer qu'elle
permet d'accompagner la victime jusqu'au
bout de la démarche il faut que le
dernier lien soit rompu entre
l'agresseur et l'agresser et que le
parcours judiciaire de la victime soit
complet le renoncement à la poursuite
civile doit alors être un choix éclairé
délester de l'emprise souvent
persistante du conjoint violent c'est un
manque propose donc de préciser que le
renoncement à la poursuite civile de
l'agresseur doit être explicite je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues avis de la
commission madame la rapporteur
oui merci
monsieur premier permet à la CAF d'être
surogé dans les droits de la victime de
ce constitue partie civile au procès
pénal si la victime renonce à exercer ce
droit le président amendement précise de
caractère explicite du renoncement de la
victime cette position n'apparaît pas
comme utile et se trouve en réalité
satisfait voilà donc la caisse exercera
les droits de la victime de manière
subsidiaire il est donc clair qu'à ce
titre il informer à l'informera
expressément la victime de son intention
d'agir en justice et que son action sera
interrompue dès lors que la victime se
constituera elle-même partie civile
il s'agit nullement de décourager les
victimes d'exercer leurs droits mais au
contraire qu'elles soient informées de
leur possibilité de demander réparation
de leur préjudice subit y compris
matériel c'est donc une demande de
retrait ou à des fois un avis
défavorable
merci madame la ministre du gouvernement
le principe de choix éclairé de la
victime pour aller jusqu'au bout de la
démarche à l'encontre de son agresseur
et bien sûr en cela nous ne pouvons qu'y
être favorables néanmoins l'amendement
tel qu'il est rédigé ne conduit pas tant
à renforcer le principe de choix éclairé
de la victime en matière de poursuite à
l'encontre de l'agresseur qu'à préciser
dans quel cas la caisse peut être
subroger en les tendant du renoncement
simple ou renoncement explicite et je
rappelle également que les alinéas 18 et
19 tels que rédigées dans la proposition
de loi et je l'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
ne conduisent pas à la mise en oeuvre
d'une solution juridiquement
opérationnelle c'est pourquoi je suis
défavorable à cet amendement
c'est Madame melbassa il est retiré
merci je mets aux voix l'article premier
avec
avec rien
qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient uneanimité
merci à l'article 2 un amendement 5
madame la rapporteur
propose une coordination avec le projet
de loi d'orientation et de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur adopté par
le Sénat ce texte prévoit donc de créer
la fonction d'assistant d'enquête pour
seconder les officiers agents de police
judiciaire pour certaines tâches de
procédure cet amendement permet donc aux
assistants d'enquête d'exercer les
nouvelles missions que le président
article 2 en tant confié à ses officiers
ou à Jean dans les commissariats ou
gendarmerie où ils seront présents les
assistants d'enquêtes seront mieux
indiqués pour enregistrer les demandes
d'avance d'urgence et de transmettre à
la CAF
merci avez du gouvernement
tout d'abord bien vous rappeler que nous
souhaitons vraiment ensemble aller plus
loin nous inspirer aussi bien sûr des
des différentes expérimentations au
dispositif qui sont en train de se
mettre en place sur les différents
territoires et je me tiendrai vraiment à
votre disposition pour que nous avions
au mieux et dans le même état d'esprit
qui est de mieux protéger les victimes
et de mieux les leur permettre de
reprendre le autonomie donc s'agissant
de cet amendement donc il semble
nécessaire que les assistants d'enquête
disposent d'une compétence d'attribution
limitée définie dans un nouvel article
21.3 inséré au code de procédure pénale
et Sanson autonomie d'intervention ce
n'est qu'à cette condition essentielle
que le Conseil d'État a admis la
validité de la disposition dans son avis
du 10 mars dernier
d'autre part il est prématuré d'ajouter
des compétences aux assistants d'enquête
alors que l'assemblée ne l'a pas encore
examiné le Sénat a d'ailleurs souhaité
évalué ce nouveau dispositif pour ces
raisons le Gouvernement émet un avis
défavorable je vous remercie
[Musique]
oui bien évidemment je maintiens le
l'amendement je pense que c'est le
moment où jamais justement puisque ils
vont exister pourquoi ne pas
comment dire proposer tout de suite
qu'il soit intéressé par par ce genre de
choses je trouve que c'est un peu
dommage de pas le mettre tout de suite
dans cette proposition de loi je
comprends pas votre votre réponse madame
la ministre c'est bon c'est votre
réponse c'est moi je maintiens bien sûr
cette amendement
bien je mets aux voix
madame l'état madame la Présidente
juste pour
remerciement notre rapporteur de donner
une possibilité supplémentaire pour
accompagner justement cette demande et
cette transmission de demande c'est vrai
que les officiers de police ou de
gendarmerie sont accompagnés de
travailleurs sociaux mais pas partout si
demain il y a des agents d'enquête
complémentaires et si dans leur
prérogatives on pouvait faire en sorte
qu'ils soient un soutien supplémentaire
pour que ces dispositions puissent être
prises en compte de la meilleure manière
possible c'est une avancée il faut
effectivement vérifier mais je pense que
c'est cohérent avec la loi que nous
avons voté tout récemment et peut-être
dire aussi à nos collègues que dans cet
article 2 il est précisé que la demande
est aussi transmise simultanément aux
présidents du conseil départemental au
moment du dépôt de plainte au moment du
signalement pourquoi pour répondre à ce
que notre collègue Michel gréaume disait
président de conseil départemental ce
sont les services sociaux du département
et l'accompagnement en utilisant
justement tous les outils globaux dont
nous disposons pour l'accompagnement des
bénéficiaires du RSA l'accompagnement
social administratif vers l'emploi et
donc cette prise en charge globale
envoie vers la caisse d'allocations
familiales le la demande d'aide et
instruction sociale et accompagnement
social immédiat en parallèle ce qui fait
que nous avons une approche globale du
dispositif ça n'est pas anodin cette
transmission au président du conseil
départemental
je mets aux voix l'amendement de la
commission avec un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'obtient
l'amendement est adopté et sincèrement
madame la ministre entre la loopmie et
ce texte dans la navette ça doit pouvoir
se régler allez
après l'article a j'ai pas fait voter
l'article de pardon sur l'article 2 qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté à
l'unanimité je vous remercie après
l'article 2 un amendement 4 monsieur
Chassin
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente madame rapporteur mes chers
collègues alors si vous voulez cette
amendement qui a été peut-être mal
rédigé puis dans mon esprit c'était si
vous voulez permettre aux mutuelles
agricoles de procéder aux côtés des cafs
au versement de l'avance d'urgence pour
les victimes de violences conjugales
ainsi si vous voulez le dispositif
risque de manquer certaines cibles qui
ont pour interlocuteur la MSA plutôt que
la cave c'est pour ça il me semble
pertinent d'ouvrir la possibilité au MSA
de procéder au versement de cette aide
donc cet amendement si vous voulez
demande l'opportunité d'ouvrir le
dispositif à la MSA et en fait je répare
dans cette amendement
sous-entendu parce que c'est
complètement évident en 35
co-cignataires l'eau interprété de la
même chose que moi donc Madame Letare et
Madame leur rapporteur ont signé ce cet
amendement et donc je souhaite
effectivement qu'il puisse être adopté
pour que les MSA aussi puissent
s'impliquer merci
bien sur un rapport je vous souhaite bon
courage monsieur Chassin avis de la
commission madame la rapporteur
oui chers collègues moi je partage
entièrement l'intention de cette
amendement au moins on peut en discuter
parce que de toute façon ça aurait été
tombé sur l'article 40 donc au moins
c'est un nom pour ça que nous l'avons
consigné avec Valérie Létard c'est que
je pense que à terme il conviendra au
caisse de la mutualité sociale agricole
de verser l'aide d'urgence à l'heure à
locataire et là je m'adresse bien sûr à
madame la ministre qui voilà je pense
que là-dessus on va s'entendre parce que
c'est vrai que il y a un trou dans la
raquette et qu'il y a important en tous
les cas chers collègues voilà que quand
le considère mais vous comprendrez bien
que comme c'est un rapport je suis
obligé de donner un avis défavorable
mais voilà mais écoutez là je crois que
simplement ce qui est important c'est
que Madame le ministrella elle a entendu
et le message est passé voilà
donc avis défavorable madame la ministre
avait du gouvernement
monsieur chasse
monsieur le Président bon je vais
retirer cet amendement mais il s'est
quand même quelque chose de totalement
évident j'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi les articles 40 là-dedans on
les personnes qui sont assujetti à la
CAF auront sa tête d'urgence les
personnes qui sont assujettées à la
messe malheureusement il y a aussi des
violences dans le rural et j'avoue ne
pas comprendre pourquoi on peut pas
associer la MSA c'est pratiquement
rédactionnel ce ça nous oublie c'est
tout mais mais bien sûr tout le monde
est sûrement d'accord pour ça merci
ah il est retiré désolé madame la
Présidente Rossignol pas de chance
c'est dommage
ah non vous pouvez pas
signature
vous pouvez
mais je le maintiens merci
mais je serai obligé de redonner la
parole à la Commission
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
la délégation droit des femmes
a travaillé de manière comme toujours
dans la délégation de droit des femmes
totalement
transpartisanes et 4 de nos collègues à
ma connaissance on produit un rapport
sur qui s'appelle les inégalités
spécifiques dans les femmes sont
victimes en milieu rural je regardais si
ma collègue m'a hyper meunier qui
s'appelle les zones blanches de
l'égalité la spécificité des inégalités
dont les femmes sont victimes en milieu
rural dans ce rapport il est très
clairement identifié que les femmes
victimes de violence en milieu rurales
sont souffrent encore plus que celles
qui sont en milieu urbain c'est clair
elle souffre encore plus parce qu'elles
ont moins de tissu associatifs moins de
d'environnement de soutien voilà je
pense donc pour nous pour moi en tout
cas manque de délégation droit des
femmes c'est une cohérence totale que de
reprendre et voter l'amendement présenté
par notre collègue Chassin
bon
madame la rapporteur
oui mais vous ne changez pas d'avis du
fait de l'intervention de ses enfants
[Musique]
il faudrait qu'elle se regroupe qu'elle
décide d'elle-même voilà je laisse le
vote tel qu'il est mais je pense que
vraiment c'est plutôt la balle et
j'espère que cette bonne
madame je vous passe la balle et je
pense que la décision vous revient parce
que c'est vrai que ça sera un coup
supplémentaire quand le veuille ou non
donc de toute façon ça tomberait sur
l'article 40 aussi
mais là on pouvait pas parce que c'est
un rapport voilà c'était un rapport donc
le rapport voilà donc je maintiens ce
que j'ai dit
allez alors j'ai madame jasmin qui veut
s'exprimer et ensuite on va voter non
non non pas de discussion dans les
laissez la parole à Madame jasmin et à
Madame jasmin seul merci
maintenant je suis
rapporteur je comprends les arguments
mais nous devons pas créer des
disparités une fois de plus parce que là
nous sommes sur un sujet sérieux la
proposition de Madame Valérie d'État
nous avons tous adhérer et je crois que
leur apport qui a été fait par la
délégation de droit des femmes avec
l'ensemble des groupes parce que tous
les groupes étaient représentés
justement et de quand on regarde les
préconisations les recommandations de ce
rapport je crois que la proposition de
notre collègue et en parfaite cohérence
en fait avec ceux qui devraient être
fait donc je crois que Madame la
Ministre lorsqu'elle a pris la parole
elle a dit qu'elle allait faire évoluer
un certain nombre de choses et d'aller
poursuivre donc je crois que nous devons
aujourd'hui voter l'amendement qui est
proposé par notre collègue et après
madame la ministre va voir ce qui en est
pour améliorer je ne sais pas mais on ne
doit pas créer des disparités entre les
femmes en milieu rurales d'autant plus
que nous avons été unanime uneanime à
reconnaître que leur absor méritait
d'être fait parce que les préconisations
qui sont faites et bien reflètent la
réalité de nos territoires et
malheureusement les femmes sont les
victimes je crois avoir compris quand
même dans le débat si vous voulez bien
me permettre que l'opposition de la
commission n'est pas lié au problème de
fond mais au fait que c'était un rapport
et seulement cela donc donc chacun sait
dans cette hébicie que les commissions
dans le Sénat ne veulent pas de rapport
donc après l'hémicycle décide
souverainement et je vais donc mettre
oui madame la Présidente l'état je crois
que on a compris
mais il vaut mieux redire les choses
pour qu'elle soit bien claires et
remercier le rapporteur c'est vrai qu'il
applique des dispositions qu'on demande
aux commissions de mettre en œuvre et de
la façon la plus exigeante possible elle
émet un avis défavorable sur une idée
qu'elle partage quelle porte parce qu'en
fait elle passe au travers d'un rapport
sinon effectivement on a une
problématique budgétaire qui fait qu'on
pourrait mettre en difficulté le texte
donc on peut s'accorder que Madame la
rapporteur tout en ayant émis un
défavorable enfin le soutien moi
allez on va dire que avec tous mes
collègues je peux pas vous laisser dire
que Madame la rapporteur dit oui en
disant non non non
monsieur le Président
exceptionnellement je voterai pour cette
amendement pour une simple raison c'est
que l'Esprit qui sous-tend effectivement
les explications justifient que on
marque le coup l'AMSA doit être intégré
madame Lamy c'est un message bien alors
madame la ministre allez allez on a
compris
merci de cet amendement alors c'est bien
je relis c'est bien cet amendement vise
à demander la remise par le Gouvernement
au Parlement d'un rapport sur
l'opportunité d'ouvrir le dispositif au
MSA en plus des CAF voilà c'est
exactement ce dont nous sommes saisis si
le dispositif épreuve d'efficacité il
apparaîtra nécessaire qu'il soit élargi
aux caisses de MSA par équité de
traitement entre les allocataires et
aussi par simplification l'accès à
l'aide pour les personnes victimes
relevant du régime agricole mais qui
pour ce prêt d'urgence sans intérêt
devront s'adresser à la CAF la
production d'un rapport n'apparaît pas
nécessaire c'est pourquoi
je rends préconiserai le retrait ou à
défaut j'aimais très un avis défavorable
allez je mets aux voix donc un
amendement qu'un avis officiellement
défavorable de la commission et des
favorable du Gouvernement nous sommes
bien d'accord quel que soit les opinions
de chacun qui est pour
quiconque
il est adopté
madame la ministre sur l'article 3 vous
ne l'avez pas le gage
non non bon je mets aux voix donc
l'article 3 tel quel qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté je vais mettre au voile
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
madame
c'est la voix totale c'est de l'ensemble
de la loi oui donc c'est l'explication
de vote général
je voulais simplement dire que je
regrettais en effet le rejet de l'étude
conjointe des deux pppl mais je tiens à
préciser qu'elle répondait aussi aux
personnes qui travaillaient au traitées
ou autres situations car c'était une
avance RSA avec révision des ressources
au bout de trois mois et ce n'était pas
sous forme de près cependant je me
réjouis aujourd'hui
de cette avancée comme je l'avais
annoncé en introduction notre groupe
votre assiette proposition de loi qui
devient complémentaire au dispositif
déjà mis en place et impératif pour
toutes ces personnes qu'il attendent et
qui en ont besoin voilà merci merci
Madame le wérou
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre donc cette proposition de loi
vise à mettre en place une avance
universelle d'urgence à taux zéro
financé par la CAF pour les victimes de
violences conjugales même s'il s'agit
d'un prêt qui sera donc à rembourser on
l'espère avec souplesse c'est un soutien
apporté à ces femmes trop souvent
confrontées à un départ sans ressources
qu'il est contraignent trop souvent à
revenir toutes les mesures de nature à
aider ces femmes à quitter le domicile
le plus souvent avec des enfants doivent
être activement soutenus 102 féminicides
en 2022 un décès tous les deux jours
madame la ministre il faudra aussi
donner les moyens aux associations qui
accompagnent ces femmes pour leur
proposer des hébergements d'urgence
adaptés et avec un accompagnement digne
de ce nom je redis qu'un logement
d'urgence au bord de la quatre voies
sans accompagnement n'est pas une
solution incitative à quitter l'enfer de
la violence conjugale une fois la crise
aigu passée et on connaît le phénomène
du cycle infernal de la violence qui
conduit à trouver des justification à sa
violence pour conduire à une phase dite
de l'une de miel qui suit la crise aiguë
jusqu'à la prochaine je salue ici aussi
l'action des intervenants sociales en
gendarmerie et commissaire et
commissariat qui doivent être
généralisés sur tout le territoire et
souligne la nécessaire formation des
policiers et gendarmes et dans les
centres hospitaliers également je
remercie la commission d'avoir intégré
l'amendement proposé par notre collègue
victoire jasmin sur la domiciliation
bancaire en CCAS et CIS ça a permis
d'améliorer le texte donc comme l'a dit
Laurence Rossignol lors de la discussion
générale notre groupe soutient avec
enthousiasme cette proposition de loi
elle n'apporte de solutions n'importe
quoi de solution miracle mais
l'indépendance économique des femmes est
une condition indispensable à leur
émancipation et nous rejoint enfin je
rejoins aussi la proposition de Laurence
Cohen concernant une loi contre les
violences conjugales merci
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Chassin
monsieur le Président tout d'abord je
voudrais
féliciter madame Letard et madame le
rapporteur pour cette proposition de loi
qui est très importante il y a bien sûr
la prévention à poursuivre madame la
ministre vous l'avez dit il y a eu des
progrès mais vous voyez bien qu'il y a
eu il y a encore beaucoup de phénicides
et il faut absolument y mettre un frein
c'est par un logement et aussi c'est par
l'aide financière que vous proposez qui
est vraiment très importante parce que
sinon la personne qui sera dépendante
financièrement reviendra dans son
logement et donc les violences
continueront et donc je voudrais
remercier aussi les personnes qui ont
voté mon amendement parce que
comme ça a été dit les violences sont
aussi en rural et il faut aussi que
l'État soutienne bien les associations
parce qu'elles ont besoin aussi de faire
des permanences en rural et souvent ça
n'existait pas et en Corrèze en tout cas
j'ai rencontré les deux associations et
pour le logement certaines sont vraiment
en difficulté parce qu'il y a une
augmentation des violences donc merci
à cette proposition de loi de Madame
Letard merci à la commission elle a
rapporteur de l'avoir enrichi bien sûr
nous nous voterons avec enthousiasme
cette proposition de loi je voudrais
qu'elle soit généralisée à tous les
départements merci merci la parole est à
la présidente l'État
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues remercier tous les collègues
sur tous les bancs pour leur
contribution leur travail et c'est
unanimité face à un sujet comme je l'ai
rappelé dans mon propos liminaire qui
dépasse largement les sensibilités
politiques et qui milite madame la
ministre que l'on ne perde pas de temps
s'il vous plaît encore une fois le
travail qui va être mené par les
professionnels qui sont d'ailleurs ici
présents et qui ont largement contribué
à à cette expérimentation et donc à la
réflexion même sur la proposition de loi
car on a travaillé sur les écueils de
l'expérimentation sur ce qu'il manque
pour pouvoir traduire concrètement une
telle initiative et qui nécessite qu'on
légifère c'est important madame Vogel
vous dire que le prêt pourquoi le prêt
parce que c'était le seul moyen
d'arriver à l'universalité c'était le
seul moyen d'arriver à ce que une
personne salariée malgré ses conditions
de ressources si elle est privée de ses
revenus elle puisse y avoir accès dans
ce temps intermédiaire et ce qui est
important c'est qu'avec la CAF nous
avons travaillé elle nous a dit le
système de l'avance sur droit supposé
trop rigide ça marche pas les prêts ça
marche et surtout il y a la possibilité
de la remise gracieuse du montant du
prêt pour les personnes ont précarité
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une solution pour
toutes les situations il faut aller au
bout de ce dispositif il a été pensé
c'est la construction qui était
compliquée maintenant la mise en
application les professionnels ils la
connaissent sur le bout des doigts on en
aura la garantie la sécurité les
affinements nécessaires mais le cadre il
est posé madame la ministre s'il vous
plaît ne perdons pas de temps je vous
remercie
merci
madame la Présidente mésovoye l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi créant une aide
universelle d'urgence pour les victimes
de violences conjugales qui éprouvent
qui compte qui s'abstient ce texte est
adopté à l'unanimité je vous remercie
nous allons suspendre madame la
rapporteur vous voulez dire quelques
mots je vous en prie
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre moi je trouve qu'il est
forte de constater que aujourd'hui
malgré toutes les lois qui existent
je veux dire qu'on n'a pas moins
malheureusement de féminicides en France
et ça je trouve que c'est inquiétant
donc je pense que la loi de Valérie
d'État est-ce que la Commission à faire
sociale a pu rajouter en tant
qu'amendement pour améliorer un peu la
loi
est important c'est une marche
supplémentaire et s'entendre dire à
chaque fois que c'est compliqué on en
parler tout à l'heure avec la Présidente
je trouve que à chaque fois qu'on dépose
une loi ici c'est compliqué alors en
France je sais pas pourquoi mais tout
est compliqué et parfois des fois c'est
même quelque chose de léger qu'on dépose
c'est pas et on a l'impression qu'on
fait la révolution en France alors
madame la ministre arrêtons de dire que
c'est compliqué avançons ensemble et
dépêchons-nous merci
très bien
on suspend sur siège quelques secondes
le temps du changement des équipes pour
le texte suivant merci Madame la
Ministre merci Madame la rapporteur
si Madame guidez veut bien laisser sa
place je sais qu'elle apprécie d'être à
porteur mais bon allez l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion de la proposition
de loi visant à accompagner la mise en
place de comités sociaux et économique à
la poste présentée par madame Denis
Saint-Pée demande du groupe Union
centriste la procédure accélérée a été
engagée sur ce texte
je vous précise tout de suite que
naturellement nous allons écouter
l'auteur de la proposition la rapporteur
la